speak to that how you doubled down on
real estate
even if you didn't expect this hot
market you said let me focus on what i'm
good at only have so much bandwidth i'm
great at this i'm going to double down
on this make my money here
and bitcoin let you guys do what you do
nfts let you do what you do you've had
these uh thoughts you've had we've had
these discussions would you mind
unpacking that no i i look i'm a firm
believer where i only invest in what i
can control so i'm not a passive
investor like i don't buy stocks i don't
invest in friends i don't invest in
these phone calls like if i'm not the
quarterback doing something i don't do
it it's just the way i am right because
i know that i'm the quarterback now not
to be said like i have friends of mine
who
you know so i have three buckets right i
do my home business that i actually love
which is tangible real estate
it's my pulse it's my energy i make it
work my second bucket is bodega which is
cinco de mayo day which is our favorite
brand amazing business
um we're actually on there we go we're
actually
expanding bodega a lot now so we're
spending a lot of time bodega we have
south beach as you know we have fort
lauderdale we have palm beach we have a
taco in aventura we're opening coconut
grove in two months um we're already a
big one in chicago so we're gonna have
probably 15 bodegas by this time next
year wow it's my favorite place to go
dancing by the way the best place to
dance always so i love bodega and my
third box is i do business with good
friends
in companies that either they run or i
know about
or you know like i'm into it so there
are deals i don't control but i know the
guys that are doing it and i'm with them
on it so the answer is
back to the crypto thing look people are
making a lot a lot of money it could be
the future and maybe we're already
obsolete maybe i'm 41 i don't get you
know why a monkey's worth a million
dollars i don't know you know i don't
understand the metaverse i'm still in
the universe like i i just don't get it
but with that's well said bro people are
making a tremendous fortune that
business people also losing trends
fortune it
goes down to
you know what works for someone
and for me like i'm not trying to get
rich quick i don't need to
buy something double it without doing
anything in two months i don't like my
money's controlled by something else
other than my hands like it's very
vulnerable to being very vulnerable like
it's funny your point we had
thanksgiving sales came in my house and
i have a nephew mine
great great guy yeah you know that's
exactly what i was thinking when we were
talking about the bitcoin i'm a nephew
of mine and you know and i i help him
out financially whenever i can and he's
a great guy so anyway he's in college so
with this conversation i said i said you
know like how much money do you have he
says to me um i've got 15 000 bucks i go
wow a lot of money
okay so it's like what do you do with it
he goes well
my friends and i you know we have a chat
you know i'm in bitcoin i'm an ether and
you know i go so you're not buying like
microsoft and yahoo and amazon he goes
no takes too long so i go let me ask
questions just throw it out there you
have 15 000 of your 15 9 thousands in e3
said yes i go what is an ether what is
it
he goes
i don't know i go she just took nine
granny or 15 and something you don't
know because the chat tells you to buy
it today and he goes
yeah it's pretty stupid and i go no it's
not stupid maybe it's smart i don't know
but like if it's me i don't take 50 of
my money but it's something i don't know
i can't control at least research and
figure out he's not getting a job in the
family business well what's crazy is his
numbers are not far off remember he had
about 15 grand keep in mind uh he's
about 20 years old junior in college
okay so at 20 years old i was lucky if i
had fifteen dollars you need another
beer braille good beer bodega by the way
adam they want to know if you're gonna
take a shot or is that for decorating
we're gonna dig a shot a hundred percent
say i said thank you for managing the
chat john john thank you for managing
the chat if people have questions we can
open up at the end and uh we're going to
definitely take a shot in a second but
we'll we'll stay here then we'll go
right into the shop but i remember
saying oh you have 15 grand how much of
that is in cash do you remember what he
said
800 bucks he said 200 bucks 200 bucks i
go 200 dollars
so all your money is in the crypto
and this is when crypto was doing pretty
well it's since then you know not done
so by the way there are guys and like i
watch cnbc a lot there are
genius guys successful guys that are
into this so like
you know it's it's here right like it's
not leaving right like bitcoin ether is
on the ticker after the down the nasdaq
right like it's literally showing every
show minute on cnbc it's real
you know i just i don't like risk as you
know and losing money
it's not for me in fact when i found
that i had some because
a partner of mine actually opened some
account bought some my money
one day he goes you know you have
uh if he was like 496 thousand dollars
in bitcoin ether i go what your jet look
at your name don't you love when that
happens
before i go can i have that money he
goes no no leave it for 10 years i go no
no no no can i please take it now and i
think i took all of it and left one coin
that i gave way to um to someone anyway
the point i was like no i'll take 496
today
verse maybe 696 in two years but i don't
want to go to 296. right so that's how
my brain works and by the way
if i left it it's probably worth the
6.96 in two years but i felt good just
going uh some of the wires
[Music]
you